[Musique]
une conférence de presse s'est tenue ce
lundi 3 septembre au palais de la source
pour lancer la 21e édition du challenge
des créateurs
ce concours initié par le département
récompense les meilleures initiatives en
matière de création d'entreprise
on le sait il ya beaucoup de réunionnais
qui ont des projets mais qu'ils n'osent
pas aller vers ce challenge et créateurs
au contraire le challenge des créateurs
ça vous permet d'être avec d'autres
jeunes ou moins jeunes qui ont des
projets et souvent cette rencontre avec
tous ceux qui ont des projets et qui
vont au challenge des créateurs
ça permet aussi de faire des liens de
tisser des liens et peut-être des liens
qui pourront dynamiser le projet qu'ils
ont et le département est là justement
pour créer cette synergie pour créer
cette dynamique le challenge des
créateurs est un véritable révélateur de
réussite puisque sur les 86 lauréats
récompensés depuis 1998 plus de la
moitié sont encore en activité en termes
de confiance en soi
en gagnent encore plus en confiance
le fait de le d'être lauréat ainsi 100%
de confiance en soi et
sa portée beaucoup de visibilité au
niveau de la
population tout simplement un métier qui
n'est pas connu de l'optique à domicile
les inscriptions se poursuivent jusqu'au
17 septembre 2018 à minuit sur le site
de la collectivité www.dtcc.com 7 4
point fr
[Musique]